when a good science team is working it's
kind of like a good band I think they
are similarities between science and
music meaning in both you try to build a
team that works for each person has its
own contribution and their own part of
the overall work to do hopefully you
know all of us see the big picture as
well but people take care of their own
original thing and when a good science
team is working it's kind of like a good
band where you could communicate just
with a you know gesture they had or a
wink or something and just know and for
the other person knows exactly what's
going on and right now that my lab has
been so well tuned it feels like a
really good band you know what it's just
gonna go where it's gonna go without any
conscious leadership it's just you know
everybody doing what they're supposed to
do
[Music]